hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show christmas special
where in this video we're going to talk
about everyone's favorite christmas
spice
cinnamon or well at least it's my
favorite spice
so you better watch out you better not
cry better not pout
i'm telling you why cinnamon is coming
to town
anyway in this video i'm going to tell
you obviously about cinnamon
and maybe some facts that you probably
didn't know about cinnamon and then go
into a bit of detail about
the proposed health benefits and also
some facts about its potential safety
and then at the end in the spirit of
christmas i'll be doing another free
giveaway
but i'll give the details to that at the
end of the video so i really like
cinnamon
if you hadn't already guessed and that's
because it smells amazing and also
tastes great
but what actually is cinnamon well
cinnamon is so
named after the tree genus from which it
obtains from
cinnamon and so there are several
different tree species
from the genus cinnamon from which you
can get cinnamon from
and it's often obtained from the inner
bark of these different tree species
and so you can buy cinnamon as dried
bark strips
or you can buy it ground up in a powder
and so cinnamon is mostly used as a
flavoring additive we add it to
different foods both
sweet and savory because let's be honest
it tastes brilliant
but where does that great taste and
smell come from well the main aroma you
get from cinnamon
comes from the organic compound
cinnamaldehyde because cinnamon isn't a
compound on its own
it is made up of various different
constituents
and so there are also other aromatic
compounds that also add to cinnamon's
aroma
for example eugenol is another aromatic
compound
that plays a key role in cinnamon's
great smell and taste
but what else can you find in cinnamon
well in 100 grams which bear in mind
it's quite a lot of cinnamon
you can find around 81 carbohydrates
most of which is dietary fiber protein
fat
and also calcium iron and vitamin k but
again remember that this is in
100 grams of cinnamon a teaspoon of
cinnamon would have more or less one to
two grams
and also this is just generic
information for cinnamon as i mentioned
earlier there are many different species
of cinnamon that you can commercially
buy
the two most common are cinnamon cassia
otherwise known as
sweet cinnamon or cassia cinnamon and
the other being cinnamon ferrum
referred to as true cinnamon or real
cinnamon
or otherwise known as ceylon cinnamon
and so
salon cinnamon is grown primarily in sri
lanka whilst
cassia cinnamon is grown in southeastern
asia
and often it's preferred to be used in
baking because it has a stronger flavor
than ceylon cinnamon and you can also
distinguish the two different types
by their visual appearance for example
calcium cinnamon is generally more a
reddish brown in color
and tends to be a bit thicker whereas
ceylon cinnamon uses only the thin
inner bark and has a much lighter brown
color but a really important difference
between the two species of cinnamon
is the fact that calcium cinnamon
contains a much greater amount of a
compound
known as coumarin now coumarin is
another aromatic compound
but it's been found that coumarin is
moderately toxic to the liver and
kidneys
and for these reasons the european food
safety authority
declared that a daily intake of 0.1
milligrams of cumulative
per kilogram body weight is the
tolerable daily intake
so anything above that may be causing a
risk for
kidney or liver damage and so for these
reasons the eu
laid down guidelines for the maximum
content of coumarin in foodstuffs
and these regulations sparks a spicy
debate
between danish bakers and food
authorities um
that was quite an interesting article
but anyway how much calcium cinnamon
would you
have to consume to go above this
tolerable daily intake of coumarin
well this is kind of hard to calculate
given that the amount of coumarin
in cassia cinnamon can fluctuate however
if we use this table as a rough estimate
for a kilogram body weight the tolerable
amount of calcium that could be consumed
according to these regulations
is between 0.4 grams to 50 grams whereas
if you compare it to sale on cinnamon
due to the low amount of coumarin more
than 50 grams of ceylon cinnamon
is tolerable to be consumed now if we
use this again as our reference point
50 grams is a lot of cinnamon but as a
mini take home so far
if you want to be on the safe side it
seems that ceylon cinnamon is the better
cinnamon to go for now besides the great
taste and smell of cinnamon
it is also often stated that cinnamon
has various health benefits
as many studies have shown therapeutic
effects of cinnamon
including its antimicrobial antiviral
anti-fungal
antioxidant anti-tumor anti-hypertensive
anti-diabetic gastroprotective and
immunomodulatory effects
so how much of this actually holds up
well a nice
2019 study did a systematic review of
all the present
human clinical trials reported by use of
cinnamon
now in this review they were
particularly focused on looking at any
adverse events reported by taking
cinnamon
and from looking at 38 different
clinical trials and
different case reports and case series
they found that the most
frequent adverse events were
gastrointestinal disorders
and allergic reactions which were
self-limiting in the majority of cases
however they do conclude that from the
available data it does suggest that
cinnamon is safe to be
used in routine diet as a spice or
flavoring agent
and it was in general well tolerated in
the controlled clinical settings
and it's only when it's used at high
doses that at first effects
should be clinically monitored but what
about its health benefits
well according to the nih websites there
have been many studies that have looked
at the impacts of cinnamon especially
for diabetes however it's really hard to
interpret this data and compare across
them
because different studies have used
different species of cinnamon in their
trials
and they've used different amounts and
different timelines and so for these
reasons there isn't really any concrete
evidence
and this is further reinforced by a
different 2019 study that also did a
systematic
review of different studies that had
looked at the effects of cinnamon and
glycemic status
in patients with type 2 diabetes and so
comparing across
18 different studies they found that
cinnamon supplementation
did reduce the serum levels of glucose
however there weren't any changes seen
in body mass index body weight waist
circumference
and the serum levels of insulin and
insulin resistance
moreover there wasn't any effects on
hemoglobin a1c
which reflects blood sugar levels over a
longer period of time
however as i stated before it's really
hard to compare between these different
studies
in particular in this case 10 other
studies didn't even identify the type of
cinnamon that was used
so what's the verdict well studies done
in people don't clearly support
using cinnamon for any health condition
and there isn't really enough
information to argue either way
so what i can say is that if you do like
cinnamon you better watch out you better
not cry
better not pout i'm telling you why
cinnamon is coming to town
or what i was trying to say was that you
should just be careful
what type of cinnamon you're consuming
due to the high amount of cumin found in
cassia cinnamon
i'd say maybe that's put you into a bit
of a christmas mood
but nonetheless this will hopefully put
you into the christmas spirits
due to my collaborations with
generalage.org anyone who comments down
below
will be entered to win 60 capsules of
pure resveratrol
valued at 35 pounds and anyone is
welcome to use my 10 percent
discount code at studentage.org which
you can use by entering
the code cheeky at the checkout so with
that i hope you have a merry christmas
and as always thanks for listening